128 places de stationnement réservées
exclusivement aux vélos en gare de
versailles château rive gauche les
usagers adeptes du deux roues peuvent
dorénavant prendre sereinement leur
train grâce avait les boules c'est sûr
que c'est pas une station vélib go qui
va améliorer la régularité des trains
mais néanmoins il ya beaucoup de gens
qui nous disent ok on comprend vous avez
des problèmes sur les trains mais au
moins est ce que moi je peux garé mon
vélo à la gare de façon sécurisée et
donc c'est très important aussi de
s'occuper de ce premier de ce dernier
kilomètre 5800 places de stationnement
ont déjà été créés à travers l'île de
france
vingt mille seront disponibles d'ici
2020 région et sncf se partagent le
financement de 120 mille euros ont été
nécessaires pour cet espace dans la cité
royale ile-de-france mobilité avec un s
c'est le nouveau nom du syndicat des
transports d'île de france s'occupe dieu
des franciliens du départ de leur
domicile jusqu'à leur arrivée au bureau
c'est à dire qu'on essaye de travailler
sur tous les petits points noirs pour
améliorer la qualité de service aux
voyageurs améliorer la qualité de
service et aussi mettre des espaces de
coworking dans la gare quand on attend
son train c'est pouvoir mettre des
recharges de portable c'est pouvoir
offrir des nouveaux services pour les
usagers le fonctionnement de ce service
est simple l'accès est possible 7 jours
sur 7 de 5h à 1h30 avec une carte navigo
en cours de validité et moyennant un
abonnement annuel de 20 euros
atout supplémentaire de ce nouvel espace
la présence de seize casiers individuels
pour recharger les vélos électriques